now here is a picture now don't you say
anything
think with me okay like I said don't
shout it out just answer up here the
question I want to give you is is this
symmetrical have a think about it
everything is it symmetrical how about
um how did this shape is that [ __ ] let
me get the lights for them I may
convince you is this is this shape so
much what what about this one no yes no
what about this one okay so so let's
well I mean it's a pattern it's an image
okay so let's think about these right
now when you look at all these images
together and in fact this time now leave
space for hitting I'll tell you what it
is in a second it's not I do actually
want you to draw on one of these it knee
let's do the letter n ends are easy okay
and after all we are seven n if you're
if you draw it in for me join it for me
what we ask this question of is it
symmetrical or not okay
the way you know you remember I tried
with the rectangle is you want to draw a
line through it which we call the axis
so that if you reflect across there you
should get the same thing on both sides
remember that now that you're so many
people see let me see what happens where
would you like me to put the line what
kind of line would let me draw and where
should it go through yeah okay so I
could drive vertical line like this
maybe you aren't honest with me okay now
you might remember when we did our kind
of limit exercises and experiments on
reflection right if I would all the
piece of paper ball and try and reflect
across this shame I kind of run into a
problem okay so for instance I'm gonna
rub off this side sad leaves only one
part of it when I do my reflection
across what happens
yeah it's exactly right this this shape
has reflectional symmetry but that's not
the end I started with is it right so
the N is not reflection or symmetrical
neither is the S you can't find a line
that you could draw through this doesn't
matter which kind of way you go all
there a second ago
all this we don't looking spiral but I
think we all agree because of what have
you said yeah you know there's something
about this there's something about this
that is symmetrical nothing fatima said
what did you say when you miss to do
this it's a before the spiral you said
something about this shape do you
remember something about another way I
could transform this change I could turn
I could rotate it instead of flipping or
reflecting you okay and you noticed if
you have a look at this if I grabbed it
took this psyche up and put it at the
top right it's doing the same shape
right and in fact not only could I do it
once I could do it a second time and I'd
still get the same shape okay so what
you find is that I can reflect see yet
symmetry but I can also rotate to get
symmetry and that's the heading of today
rotational symmetry okay yeah it's very
good in fact all the shapes that I
showed you all the shapes I showed you
instead of reflecting across a line
redraw your and again can you do that
for me if you reach all your n you don't
want a line you don't want to lie it
back at you what it is a point
okay now because this end here right at
the end that I drew by accident
this is reflectional symmetry but it's
across a line so that's why you might
remember this girl he caught it
wine symmetry so this is reflection off
or line symmetry okay whereas this guy
here it's not about a wine at all no
mine is required it's just the point
okay so we call this rotational symmetry
because you have to spin around or
because it's about a point where's the
called point symmetry now all of these
are different kinds of symmetry and
they're all important okay a symmetry in
fact you might remember when I talked
about geometry
what do some what does metree mean it
has to do with me it's got the same root
word as video has me with measurement
right to him like the metric system
does anyone know is they all know what
happens what it means when you have this
sin this sym perfect on the front of a
word there are words you know so when we
have symmetrical can they go through any
are the ones there's a musical word
that's not to assume you've got a
symphony well you've got a whole bunch
of people and they play that's just the
name
you've got symphony you've already
secreto you might also have simultaneous
what these things are is an agreement
that's what sin means agreed so a
symphony is agreement in sound right
funny as they like telephone okay an
agreement in sound
this is an agreement in time when things
are happening simultaneously and this is
an agreement in measurements right it's
not the same but it's got the same idea
the principle underneath is very very
similar okay now last thing before I
show you something really cool so I'll
show you this right
do you remember like I looked at this is
the square if you're a reflectional
symmetry then it has the more reflection
symmetrical it is no more axes of
symmetry it has now want you to turn
your heads back to the UM the objects
you made last week right now have a look
at some of them you'll notice the vast
majority don't have one axis of symmetry
right one axis but in fact if you look
at the one right next step a be that
blue one it's second from the bottom
next to Maria's glasses can you see it
good we won't yep thank you that one do
you notice it's got more than one axis
of symmetry how many is it got it's got
at least two maybe four right so okay
turn to the front again to the front the
more axes of symmetry something has the
more reflection suitry it has but here
the more times you can rotate a shape
around remember I showed you the UM you
measure these guys how many times can
you turn this around to get the same
shape well I think it's who here's the
starting point is the starting point if
I turn it upside down 180 degrees it's
the same shape and I'm gonna - yeah
exactly facing direction when I turn it
back around I turned it twice and I got
two versions of it so what I mean is in
the space of one whole turn how many
times do I see the same coffee now have
a look at this shape in the in the space
of one the whole turn three mg series
how many times do I see the same shape
three times right here's the first one
and I'll turn it the second one I'll
turn it one last time third one so it's
dinner axes of symmetry which is what we
talked about with this we call these
orders
or symmetry we give it a different name
because it's a similar kind of idea how
much symmetry does it have but it's
different
it's about spinning its average hating
not about reflecting okay